now while these talks continue we've  also been hearing about plans from the  government to  uh allow companies to use agency staff  in future during start strike so that is  being discussed now  mick lynch when i put that to him said  well you know where are you going to  find people who are adequately trained  to be able to deal with  high power levels you know that you're  needed to run the trains um the business  secretary kwazii kwa tang  has responded uh to that accusation  about safety this is what he had to say  i don't think uh that's the case because  the employers who use them still have to  maintain the highest health and safety  standards there's no question that those  standards can be uh lowered  to accommodate these workers it's going  to be fine it's going to be absolutely  the right thing  for to have that flexibility